oh got some more stars gladys knight
gladys knight hello
yeah that's not gladys knight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's actually dionne warwick
got some more stars gladys knight gladys
knight hello
the incident happened at what could be
serena williams final u.s open lots of
celebs were there to cheer on the tennis
legend like dion who was incorrectly
id'd as fellow legendary singer gladys
got some more stars gladys knight gladys
knight hello
dion known for her deliciously shady
tweets absolutely aced her response to
the mix-up i have a voice in my opinion
hi i'm gladys knight and instead of
taking that midnight train to georgia i
won't walk on by but we'll say a little
prayer for you
and gladys she reacted too writing that
she's been sisters with dion for a long
time and hopes she is as honored to be
mistaken for me as i would be her i'm
sure it was an honest mistake
as far as the commentator responsible
for the now viral moment
got some more stars gladys knight gladys
knight hello
it's former grand slam champion turned
broadcaster chanda rubin who told et it
was simply an accident if there is no
chance that i would mistake
dion warwick for gladys knight first
things first i mean i know gladys i'm
honored to have had conversations with
her she loves tennis she's been at
tournaments over the years i have a
picture of her and her brother in my
office that's one of my favorite photos
and you know whenever i see her we can
chat and and it's just it's been
tremendous so there's no chance i
wouldn't mistake her um for the other
great zeon warwick she explains how the
mix-up really happened at that moment
when all this happened i was watching
the court and calling it off the court
not noticing our program monitor that's
more the job of my co-colleague who was
alongside me and so mid-thought my
colleague
mentioned there's gladys knight and we
had been seeing her on our on the
jumbotron that we can see the whole
stadium we can see all the celebrities
that were in the house they put them on
the big screen and we sort of talk about
it and enjoy the moment and so gladys
had been there and so when she said
gladys i echoed her immediately without
really looking at what was on program
when we put the picture back up on
program after the point was played i
realized
is that the picture we said was gladys
knight that is not that is dion warwick
and so we kind of had a laugh about it
in the booth real time we kept it light
and we kept it moving so
definitely didn't think i would wake up
and kind of have it trending seems like
all this racket is really just silly and
all that's left to do is
keep smiling
keep shining
knowing you can always count on me
[Music]
you